♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est la deuxième villeueueue,
moins visitée qu'Amsterdam,
mais qui se développe de manière
spectaculaire. Une ville
complètemerurururuite durant
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,t te
selon dedadadadards modernes.
Rotterdam compte 600 000etetetn
s'îîîît de cinq à 6000
personnes par année surererererr
maison de banlieue il y a un pe,
dans une sorte de petit village,
qui compte une quinzaine de
tours de différentes hauteurs.
- So this is it.
- This is it?- Yeah.
- Les tours sont relr r r r des
passerelles et groupées trois
par trois. Avec une terrasse
GOGOGOGOR GELUK, architecte Comx
Urban Landscape Design
- Le but du projet, c'estrereree
et le vieux quartier. Pour ça,
nous avons construit beaucoup
d'allées et de petites places.
nous avons 320 appartements.AuAx
et encore des petits cafés,
Tout ça c'est vivant. Pour
la vie sociale, c'est
de faire une mixture.
Tout le monde qui veut venir
ici, est bienvenu.
le concept du commer
dans l'espace résidentiel?
important aussi de faire
une connexion spacieuse.
La place qui ouvre...
- Et est-ce que les gens qui
habitent là-bas viennent ici?
- Donc ça marche?
- Ça marche.
♪ ♪ ♪tititititititititititititii
au-dessus du sol et pourtant,
il y a de la végétation partout.
C'est une des grandes
densification à Rotterdam;
l'aménagement d'ess ves ves vest
en particulier de toits verts.
Paul van Roosmalen est le grand
à Rotterdam.
Il y a sous le sol, un système
de capture et de rétention
les plantes, même par période
de grande esesesesse.
Des programmes de subventions
provenant de la ville, d d d d t
néerlandais et même de l'Union
européenne sont disponibles
pour verdir les toits, anciens
Autre particularité
de la densific
néerlandaise, la promotion de
modes de trans
L'urbaniste en chef
de Rotterdam, c'est lui.stststse
de densification et de
revitalisation de la ville.
Les premiers programmes
de densification de Rotterdam
aisée, dans des appartements
luxueux. Aujourd'hui, on est
dans l'approche inverse.
Chaque nouvetetetetetetetetetete
logements sociaux et une bonne
moitié de logements abordables.
La politique de densification
pour faire face aux défis posés
par les changeclclclclimatiques.
Reste à voir jusqu'où on peut
aller dans cette voie,écécécécéé
et la vie privée.
♪ ♪